trump campaigning in nevada tonight as
early voting kicks off across the state
this weekend
thank you so much for joining us tonight
at six o'clock i'm sasha loftis
orco mana joins us live in the newsroom
now with a closer look at the trump
team's effort here in the silver state
orco
well sasha president trump spoke to a
crowd of thousands of supporters at the
carson city airport he just wrapped up
his speech about 10 minutes ago
after speaking for about an hour and a
half the president touting his
achievements in the white house
and blasting what he calls joe biden's
failed career in washington
president trump's visit comes as early
voting kicks off across nevada and with
election day just over
two weeks away trump encouraging
everyone to get to the polls
at this evening's rally the president
continued to focus on
what he considers his greatest
accomplishment as president
boosting the american economy he said
before the covet 19 pandemic
the economy was thriving under his
leadership and trump also said with this
year's election
nevadans have a choice between a trump
super recovery or abide in depression
when you vote for me prosperity will
search your taxes will be cut
even further and i gave you the biggest
tax cut
in the history of our country we'll
fully resume
the nevada tourism and hospitality
industry which is fantastic we'll come
roaring back
and it will and next year will be the
greatest economic year
in the history of our country trump also
continued to criticize
joe biden he blasted biden's coronavirus
plan
saying biden will continue to keep the
states and the country closed
the president also taking some time to
discuss the controversy surrounding
hunter biden the nevada state democratic
party released a statement
about trump's visit to nevada saying in
part quote
instead of pulling another campaign
stunt trump should focus on getting
relief to nevada families who are
suffering
because of his failure to lead live in
the newsroom tonight orc omana 8 news
now